laissez les collégiens s'exprimer à
travers l'art c'est le but du projet
graff mis en place par le conseil
départemental dans neuf collèges de
l'île à la saline-les-hauts les collège
célimène gaudieux participent à ce
projet avec l'aide de leur professeur
d'arts plastiques est un artiste
les élèves sont là sur la base du
volontariat donc il y avait
c'est des élèves de 4e qui ont déjà donc
trois années de bagages de pacage d'arts
plastiques
ils sont venus ici en dehors des cours
d'arts plastiques
le mercredi après midi et le samedi pour
pouvoir créer avec l'artiste et ils sont
tout à fait en jouer c'est comme une
cour de récréation
pur bonheur l'artiste le but de ce
projet est d'instruire les élèves sur sa
démarche artistique
l'artiste a souhaité que les élèves
aient le choix du thème et du sujet
qu'ils veulent illustrer lui il est là
pour les encadrer déjà la première
fresque on a fait cet été sur le thème
de l'art du cirque et des arts en
général du coup on a créé des
personnages en amont avec les élèves
pendant une séance du 6 heures ou là on
a fait nommer établi des croquis on a
dessiné une unis sont ils ont vu un peu
les personnages qu'ils auraient aimé
voir dans l'ordre dans leur collège et
on m'a après le but était de récupérer
ses dessins des réinterpréter des sondés
mettront en dessin sur nyon avec le bien
sûr
des élèves fiers d'avoir participé à
l'embellissement de leur établissement
mais également heureux d'avoir pu
profiter du savoir faire et des conseils
de bonne heure l'artiste qui les
accompagnent
à dessiner dans six heures
nous a
guidés puis on a fait nous même le
dessin n'a fait des graffitis à côté de
la salle de maths parce que baisse il ya
plein de chiffres et puis on a fait des
des instruments à côté de la salle de
musique et puis là on a fait parce que
on peut le préau et quand il pleut
bayonne s'applique ici et les élèves il
s'intéresse aux graffitis là on apprend
des choses et c'est une grande
découverte pour nous les élèves le
conseil départemental a doté le collège
d'une subvention de 5000 nouveaux afin
de permettre la mise en oeuvre de ce
projet